there are many iconic Michael Jordan
Championship photos but have you noticed
that he's only wearing one shoe in a few
of them no they weren't stolen and
there's no big conspiracy theory but one
person close to the Bulls asked MJ for a
favor that became a tradition in 1991
Bulls PR exact Tim halam asked MJ for
one of his game warn sneakers after the
Bulls won their first championship and
after MJ accepted his offer it became a
tradition for him to give halem with one
of his game warn sneakers after winning
the finals and MJ being MJ believe this
to be a sign of good luck how went on to
collect a sneaker from all six
Championship runs forming the dynasty
collection which was acquired by fine
ears company s the Beast that has risen
to about $10 million all for the
Nostalgia Vibes crazy how a simple
request can lead to some good luck and
six championships